[Music]
the eu
has helped make european shipping
cleaners safer and fairer
[Music]
in 1986 a level playing field for
shipping companies was created thanks to
european legislation
it removed barriers for operators
counted protectionism from countries
outside the block
and made pricing fairer
further liberalization of the transport
and passenger markets came in 1992
relaxing rules in the short haul market
this allowed companies from one country
in the block
to sail between the ports of another
member state
at the turn of the millennium not one
but two disasters struck which would
shape eu maritime legislation
in 1999 the oil tanker erica sank near
france
prestige another tanker full of heavy
oil sank near spain
three years later the environmental
catastrophes led to the creation of the
eu maritime agency
and better compensation for the victims
of oil spills
that legislation included the
introduction of stronger hulls for
tankers
stricter mandatory inspections
blacklisting dangerous ships from eu
ports
and black box data recorders
[Music]
parliament backed rules making shipping
even safer in 2003
increasing standards in both passenger
and cargo transport
better protecting people and the
environment against accidents and
negligence
[Music]
preventives
in 2005 as europe's roads became
increasingly congested with lorry
traffic
parliament called for short-haul
shipping as an alternative to road
transport
then it backed gradually reducing toxic
sulfur in marine fuel in 2012
as part of the drive to save lives and
make the shipping industry cleaner
data nuclear library and i had to be an
ill mass australian
today shipping still accounts for about
2.5 percent of global greenhouse gas
emissions
parliament is calling for climate
neutral eu maritime transport by 2050
with clean ports the phasing out of
heavy oil and more research
into green technologies and fuels